we're asked how many inches are in four
and a half yards and we'll do it a
couple of ways one we could just say how
many inches are in four yards and how
many inches are and a half a yard and
this is really four plus one half yards
or we can convert this into an improper
fraction first and then convert but
before I even do that let's just think
about how many inches there are in a
yard so if I have one yard if I have one
yard we know that there are we know that
there are three feet we know that there
are three feet for every one yard right
and when you say wait why do you why am
i multiplying by three instead of saying
there's one yard for every three feet
and the easiest way to think about it is
you what you're going to have a larger
value over here and you're also you're
also going to want to have these units
right over here cancel out so yard is
cancelling out with yard so you have one
yard is equal to is equal to three feet
which is kind of what we already knew
I'm just showing you how the dimensions
cancel out and how many inches are there
per foot well we know that there are 12
inches there are 12 inches for every 1
foot and same logic over here inches is
a smaller unit of measurement so it
makes sense that we're multiplying by 12
3 feet is going to be more inches we're
multiplying by 12 and also these units
cancel out foot in the numerator foot in
the denominator 3 times 12 divided by 1
is equal to 36 36 inches so you might
have already known it but this is nice
to have the dimensions cancel out like
this we know that one yard is equal to
36 36 inches or there are 36 inches for
every one yard and so that we can now
either break this down or we could turn
this into an improper fraction first
I'll just break it down into 4 yards
plus 1/2 yards so we could say that this
is 4 yards so 4 yards is going to be
equal to well let's just multiply it
times 36 inches 36 inches for every one
yard the yards cancel out 4 times 36 is
120 plus 24 so that's 144 so this is
equal to 144 144 inches that's just the
4 yards and then if we do the half yards
if we do the half yards so one half of a
I guess I just say one half yard once
again times thirty six inches per yard
the yards cancel out one half times 36
is going to be equal to 18 inches 18
inches so 4 and 1/2 yards the same thing
as 4 yards plus one half yards which is
the same thing as 144 inches plus 18
inches which is going to give us let's
just add it up over here on the right
144 plus 18 4 plus 8 is 12 4 plus 1 is 5
you have this one up here so it's 6 and
then we have a 1 so when you add them
all together you get 162 inches the
other way to do this would have been to
convert this into an improper fraction
and then multiply by the unit so let's
do it that way if I have 4 and 1/2 of
anything really
so let me write 4 and a half trying to
find a suitable color so if I have 4 and
a half this is the same thing this is
the same thing 4 is the same thing as 8
halves this is the same thing so let me
write it this way 4 and 1/2 the same
thing as 4 plus 1/2 which is the same
thing as 4 if we want to have a same
denominator as this 2 over here or is it
just 1/2 over here this is the same
thing as 8 over 2 or you could say 4
over 1 is the same thing as 8 over 2 if
we won't have a common denominator so 8
over 2 plus 1 over 2 actually let me
write it that way just so you really
understand what we're doing 4 is the
same thing as 4 over 1 so it's 4 over 1
plus 1/2 if we want to find a common
denominator it's 2 so 4 over 1 is the
same thing as 8 over 2 plus 1/2 which is
equal to 9 halves now I did it this way
which takes longer just so you really
understand how we converted it why it
makes hopefully conceptually how why it
just makes intuitive sense why 4 and 1/2
is the same thing as 9 halves but if you
want a simple process for it you could
just say look 4 times 2 is 8 8 plus 1 is
9 and that gives you that 9 right over
there so 9 halves so we have 9 1/2 yards
that we want to convert to inches so we
have 9
half yards that we want to convert to
inches
same process times 36 inches times 36
inches per yards yard in the numerator
yard in the denominator we are left with
9 over 2 times 36 times we could say
times 36 over 1 if we like times 36 over
1 36 inches for every 1 yard 36 or the
number 36 really is the same as 36 over
1 and then we're left with just inches
in our units we're just left with inches
and over here there's several ways that
we can simplify it probably the easiest
way to simplify it is we can divide both
of our numerator and our denominator by
2 so let me write it this way I don't
want to skip step so we have 9 times 36
over 2 times 1 or over 2 inches and we
can divide the numerator and the
denominator by 2 to simplify it they're
both divisible by 2 36 divided by 2 is
18 2 divided by 2 is 1 so we're really
just left with 9 times 18 inches and you
just we can just multiply 9 times 18 let
me do it over here
18 times 9 8 times 9 is 72 1 times 9 is
9 plus 7 is 100 or it's 16 so we get 162
inches so all of this simplifies to 162
inches and we are done